[Music]
do you have other ways of saying no that
you uses two default language or
anything like that because people see
what you do right you mean you have so
much in the air and you're getting so
much done but they they don't see the
thousands of things you say no - right I
can say right now I am I am so honest
right now I'm so honest that it is it's
so it's ridiculous right like right now
I am I am no carries it absolutely not
no 40 years old
but I got time to be around push for
know why I just don't want to do it I
don't want to do that I shouldn't have
to explain why I want to do something I
shouldn't have to explain that's it
that's the thing that people have to
overcome there's a portion of life that
you go through where you feel guilty for
saying that you don't want to do certain
things that's not fair because when you
do want to do things the celebrations
and as happy times but you're allowed to
not want to do
you're allowed the option to say no you
say no for things that work for you then
good for you you can be saying no to
opportunity for all I know you're
allowed the option to say no and to not
want to participate or not want to do
that's your choice and anything I know
that and I'll make sure that I use my
nose wisely there's a lot of yeses so
and there isn't no understand that for
example I love my fans I love my fans
take pictures of fans all the time go
back and pull for fans all the time make
myself available before red carpets
after carpets movie premieres not movie
premieres I'm talking about seeing them
stopped all pictures videos but if I'm
with my
kids no Kevin Keith I said no I
shouldn't have to explain to you I'm
with my family I shouldn't have to do
that I'm entitled to know that's why you
got two options you got yes and no you
thought maybe in there that's your
choice I'm is it yes or no so as you get
older you start to see that a little
more clear and I joke around about it
but it's so true you ever notice how
direct and honest old people are get for
sure have you ever noticed the old
person does not waste time
no yeah do it no get your ass up buddy
whatever it is it's it's it's direct
because they don't have the time they
don't have the time to to play those
games
I don't either I don't I don't play
those games anymore
you